first thing I should say is that the
math community is a wonderful community
and we take joy in what we do and we
love helping people see the world
through a mathematical lens at the same
time I would say that we suffer from the
same problem that maybe our broader
culture does and that we often idolize
achievements and we think that we the
problem with that is that you end up
thinking that's the only certain people
if they're going to achieve at the
highest levels belong in mathematics it
would be like saying you know in music
saying that math that music is only for
the Beethoven's in the box rather than
saying that everybody can enjoy music
and everybody can create music and so
what happens then in mathematics if you
fall into that trap is that you end up
thinking that certain people or math
people when certain people aren't math
people and so bias can creep in we can
inadvertently stretch shepherding some
people to math and other people not to
math and I would say no it masses for
everybody
math helps everybody flourish no matter
what profession you end up in so
everybody should should learn and join
more math